pausa en el vídeo y traten de encontrar
cuál es la suma de 71 + 24 vamos a
resolverlo juntos primero veamos qué
significa 71 tenemos un 1 en la posición
de las unidades y tenemos una unidad que
es esta y en el lugar de las decenas
tenemos un 7 así que tenemos 7 grupos de
10 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 7 grupos de 10 así que
esto significa 7 decenas y una unidad
aquí tenemos 71 cajas a esto le vamos a
sumar 2 decenas y las vemos aquí una
decena y dos decenas y cuatro unidades
esto a que será igual primero veamos las
unidades tenemos una unidad y luego
cuatro unidades más lo que nos da cinco
unidades las contamos juntas y tenemos
cinco unidades una unidad más cuatro
unidades es igual a cinco unidades
y ahora veamos las decenas aquí tenemos
siete decenas más dos decenas y si las
combinamos todas juntas vamos a tener
nueve de estos grupos de diez nueve
decenas siete decenas más dos decenas es
igual a nueve decenas así que nos quedan
nueve decenas que son las que vemos aquí
y cinco unidades que otra forma tenemos
de decir nueve decenas y cinco unidades
pues 95 y con esto terminamos